und das ist alternativlos erinnern sie
sich noch an diesen berühmten satz für
sie war so vieles alternativlos die
bankenrettung alternativlos auch die lok
downs angeblich alternate angela merkel
ja alternativlos dieses wort hat angela
merkel geprägt entscheidungen zu denen
es angeblich keine alternative gab und
jetzt übernimmt der nächste diesen satz
alternativlos das sagt jetzt auch robert
habeck die neue gas umlage sie soll eben
jetzt auch alternativlos sein so hat der
wirtschaftsminister diese neuen teuer
schock für uns alle am abend im zdf
begründet es ist natürlich so dass es
für politiker nicht attraktiv ist höhere
belastungen zu verkünden es ist ein
schritt der zumutung bereithält für
deutschland umgekehrt hätten wir keine
lösung für ein geschäftsmodell also
einnahmemöglichkeiten für die
unternehmen gefunden die russische gas
ausfälle jetzt kompensieren müssen mit
der deutsche energiemarkt in die knie
gegangen und dann hätten sehr viele
bürgerinnen und bürger jetzt sich einen
neuen verbraucher suchen müssen oder gar
keinen mehr gefunden für weitaus höhere
preise deswegen ist das ein harter
schritt aber einer der notwendig ist wie
so viele entscheidungen in diesen tagen
jetzt hat sich die frage stimmt das ist
diese gasanlage wirklich alternativlos
geht es nicht anders als das millionen
gaskunden nun die industrie retten
müssen der kanzler olaf scholz der sucht
zeitgleich nach alternativen zu
russlands gas macht das hier mal richtig
üblen wetter in norwegen aber der ist
abgeblitzt er wollte mehr gas von dort
bei seinem besuch am abend aber die
norweger die haben ihm gesagt nie
kanzler das wird nichts wir haben nicht
mehr gas für deutschland also kein
erfolg bei dieser kanzler reise dabei
hat er noch gesagt auf norwegen kann man
sich verlassen umso mehr werden wir alle
energie sparen müssen dazu fordert uns
die politik ja ständig auf und darüber
hat frank plasberg am abend auch mit
seinen gästen getoppt in der ard und
dabei hatte der spd-chef in eine so
eigentlich einfache und wichtige frage
gestellt werden millionen schüler in
diesem winter frieren müssen werden da
auch die heizungen runtergedreht
hsg 19 grad maximalen öffentlichen
gebäuden am liebsten august geht es
eigentlich auch für schulen
stark sich gesagt nicht dass jemand nein
gilt nicht nicht für schulen okay ist
dann demnach auch eine soziale
einrichtung
das ist unser moment waren die streiten
dort über die folgen des gas notstands
über ja die preise darüber wer sparen
muss und die spd-chefin wird einfach nur
gefragt was ist jetzt eigentlich mit den
schulen was ist mit millionen schülern
und schülerinnen müssen die frieren im
winter was ist da die regelung erst sie
hat sich damit bisher offenbar nicht
beschäftigt müssen wir uns noch einmal
angucken
aber es gibt 19 grad maximal in
öffentlichen gebäuden am liebsten auch
und büros geht es eigentlich auch für
schulen
stark sich gesagt nicht dass jemand nein
gilt nicht nicht für schulen ist demnach
auch eine soziale einrichtung
ich finds ja noch erstaunlicher dass sie
versucht mit ist an demnach eine soziale
einrichtung da irgendwie
so wichtig ist um die sich die politik
offenbar bisher nicht geschert hat was
ist eigentlich mit dem frieren in
deutschlands klassen ja was es mit den
heizungen hat niemand bisher irgendwas
geregelt wir müssen über die neue gas um
lage sprechen es ist ein schock für
millionen deutsche wird diese gas umlage
zu mehr armut führen in deutschland das
ist die große frage die sich jeder
bürger in deutschland stellt in jedem
fall berichtet unser reporter schon
jetzt kommen immer mehr menschen zu den
tafeln zur essensausgabe und auch wegen
der explodierenden energiepreise ist ja
klar
deutschland im teuer schock die kosten
für gas und strom explodieren und auch
ansonsten steigen die preise so im
supermarkt die folge bei den tafeln
bilden sich lange schlangen eine umfrage
unter 600 tafeln im juni ergab die zahl
der hilfsbedürftigen dort hat sich seit
anfang des jahres um mehr als die hälfte
erhöht auf rund zwei millionen kunden
früher standen hier die wirklich armen
für lebensmittel schlange doch nun wird
das klientel zunehmend bürgerlich denn
die inflation bringt auch
normalverdiener
ihre grenzen entlastung ist nicht in
sicht im gegenteil der preis haben wir
bei den energiekosten ist bei den
verbrauchern ja noch gar nicht
angekommen gas umlage sowie wegfall des
tank rabatt und des neuen euro tickets
dürften die inflation im herbst noch
einmal ansteigen lassen fürchten
wirtschaftswissenschaftler auf bis zu
zehn prozent
kein wunder dass die tafeln an ihre
grenzen kommen die lebensmittel spenden
reichen nicht mehr aus auch an helfern
fehlt es vielerorts schon ein drittel
der tafeln in deutschland hat deshalb
einen aufnahmestopp für neue kunden
verhängt
und unsere reporter sind gleich dort bei
den tafeln gleichschalten wir an die
essener tafel live in dieser sendung ja
mehr armut durch die steigenden
energiepreise das gas ist ja das eine
und jetzt wird auch noch der strom
massiv teurer nach der gaskrise also
auch noch die strom krise in deutschland
die gaspreise schießen seit monaten ins
unermessliche die folge steigende
inflation wir alle müssen deutlich
tiefer in die taschen greifen und jetzt
der nächste schock eine megawattstunde
strom zum preis von
352 euro vor einem jahr lag der noch bei
82 euro der preis vervierfacht für
kommenden september betragen die
erhöhungen im schnitt noch einmal
47,4 prozent ein normaler haushalt
müsste also jetzt mit knapp 1000 euro
mehr für strom pro jahr rechnen dass der
strompreis derzeit so durch die decke
geht hat mehrere gründe
erstens wir sind zu abhängig von
fossilen energieträgern erdgas und kohle
wurden großteils aus russland importiert
2 die verstromung von gas darauf hat
deutschland in den letzten jahren ganz
besonders gesetzt um den atom und kohle
ausstieg zu kompensieren und drittens
wir sind zu spät zu spät mit dem ausbau
von erneuerbaren energie putins gasstopp
trifft deutschland also noch härter gas
und strom hängen also zwangsläufig
zusammen der strom spart spart also auch
gas
[Musik]